lundi dernier à aprikian m'a piégé en
venant sur ce plateau ara aprikian pour
ceux qui nous rejoignent c'est le très
grand patron deux des huit ans je vous
le dis au dessus de lui à la grande
ourse et il a même la même je t'aimais
fichu par terre on va regarder cet
extrait est aujourd'hui je sais qu'à
wright en grosse réunion qui reviendra
tout à l'heure on va s'occuper de lui
c'est parti ce qui fait la force du
problème surtout contrairement aux
premiers numéros
j'avais un peu envie de venir
bref prendre les fiches à wigan a dû
faire un peu
l'adie la radio tu arrêtes l'attention
mais en double ou en maladie avec david
walsh pour aller au bureau
et l'erreur hier d'arras est vrai que
c'est que valérie damidot et moi on est
on est comme ça et non des peut-être
comme ça là quand il est déguisé on les
voit que dans le grand cabaret ces
dégâts ils viennent de sauver mais vous
allez voir je pense qu'ils font que
c'est génial elle des vélos non mais
c'est le grand dont le jet pack look
s'est barré alors on y va
valérie damidot est avec nous valérie
est ce que vous m'entendez je vous
entends cyril je suis là je suis au
taquet valérie merci d'être là ma
valérie loup vous savez que je vous aime
je vous aime aussi vous savez et bon
anniversaire valérie merci ses
adversaires de valérie la vidéo hier les
vieilles valérie j'aimerais je suis car
un départ appris qu'un dock le grand
patron dieu merci
j'aimerais que vous vous occupiez de son
bureau tout à fait j'ai des mes deux
amis avec moi d'accord et elle vous a
tous là vous êtes dans le bureau d'arras
et donc du roda rafah gaza on peut
montrer déjà de bureaux regarder les
magnifiques
il a encore gardé le bon années 2015
voilà en face a manqué un peu de
personnalité et on va s'en occuper
d'accord faites vous plaisir vous savez
lui il a gardé une âme d'enfant
c'était bien ce que je comptais faire un
truc une thématique sur l'enfance est un
truc un peu rassurant régressif hockey
avec beaucoup de couleurs vous avez des
déménageurs vous des manèges et où tout
à fait j'ai j'ai mes deux copines ils
sont 12 derrière il ya une équipe de
d'un bon centre à du budget sur cette
émission
alors non j'ai pas bien compris
l'histoire de jeter les meubles par la
flak sur la benne j'ai pas tout compris
puisque c'est très haut quand même un
web et n'inquiétait pas et valérie
faites ce que vous voulez ceara qui
paiera d'accord ok valérie damidot
donc ça y est ça commence en rigoler je
suis en train lui fracasse bureau et
chantera ce fait il est garant à huy
valérie donc vous êtes dans le bureau du
patron de débite ouais c'est ça et vous
sortez tout on a tout sorti même la tam
qui pèse 8000 kg et sont 12 à la portée
mais je sais lui il apportait cochrane
l'a dit haut et fort oui il ya 20012 de
câbles et ben merci merci valérie et
sans rigoler je vous jure on va avoir de
très gros problèmes
ils sont et ce qu'ils sont pas allés un
peu trop long valérie blais appelé
stéphane plaza qui loue le bureau je
pense que le gars ne peut plus jamais
bossé que je vais nous pouvons la
roulade or en plus c'est assez marrant
je passe d'affaires on va faire un petit
point avec valérie que valérie damidot
et dans le bureau du patron elle va tout
redécorer mafia loge alors là je galère
écoute on est en train de finaliser
l'intérieur avec mon équipe de choc non
suis-je d'ailleurs je vais te les
débaucher tous eu son formidable là je
finalise sa jacques c'est sur les
apports ce que je voudrais qu'ils
rentrent dans un truc où tu vois c'est
déjà une star ouais tu vois on est parti
sur un dollar
là je suis devant la porte de son bureau
il m'avait mis un petit mot oui mais en
fait donc du coup je suis parti là
dessus j'ai fait l'effort de que m quand
tu fais un truc un peu ce maire valérie
on va vous retrouver dans un instant et
on va voir le résultat et on va faire un
petit point il valérie damidot pour tous
ceux qui nous rejoignent ça chez carat
appris qu'ils ont le grand patron de 2,8
c'était la semaine dernière a pris mes
fichiers les arts complètement série les
portières donc on a envoyé valérie mon
amie ma soeur mama mama ma vie valérie
donc qui a redécoré le bureau d'art a
appris quand il n'est pas là il va
revenir tout à l'heure de réunions donc
il va découvrir ça on espère pendant
l'émission
valérie est ce que ça y est c'est fait
est ce qu'on peut voir le résultat
déjà on valoir le bureau avant est ce
que jérôme revon peut nous montrer le
bureau le bureau d'avant alors allez-y
valérie match hérissé table alors il ya
eu un petit avant il y avait beaucoup de
travail j'ai une équipe formidable et si
les garçons tout ça n'a fait un boulot
de dingue ce que je peux dire c'est clan
leur créer tout un univers meilleurs
atouts il a un petit bureau formidable
un espace réflexion pour les nouvelles
émissions
d'ailleurs ce problème
regarde voilà way son petit bureau alain
petit bureau regarder un petit téléphone
pour appeler il pourra t'appeler jour et
nuit je vais fait un cellulaire aussi je
les fais un petit mot pour lui expliquer
que sera pas là parce que je n'assume
pas du tout cette décoration
et si un jour on est amené à travailler
ensemble j'ai fait envie qu'ils me
virent avant de démarrer alors voilà il
ya de l'univers de l'enfance a galéré et
ça c'est le aaa rat ne verra jamais il
vous aime c'est moi qui va virer vous
habitez pas écouter ce qu'on peut faire
c'est que déjà j'assume 50% de la déco
vous assumer les 50 autres ok tout cas
il a son univers le gard à y bien là bas
ils valent bien valérie bercy valérie je
vous embrasse très très fort
cette série à les valider et si on
attend de voir les joueurs il a dû avoir
des textos qui ont dû lui dire hanouna
il emprunte mais il c'est parce qu'il va
voir non il va arriver dans le bureau
tout à l'heure j'espère qu'on va être à
l'antenne son va voir sa tête
et justement parlant tête il ya des
têtes qui vont tomber on va retrouver
notre patron ça y est on me dit qu'il
arrive dans les locaux on l'a bloqué on
l'a dit de ne pas ouvrir la porte de son
bureau pour l'instant à l'amour de mecs
c'est vraiment un amour de mec vraiment
je tenais à le dire il est super il est
génial c'est notre patron il avait jeté
mes fiches la semaine dernière on avait
dit qu'on allait se mange et on a eu
notre amie valérie damidot qui est venu
tout à l'heure et quart des corps est
complètement son bureau est-ce qu'on
peut revoir le bureau maintenant on va
pas le revoir il va le découvrir
lui-même ara aprikian c'est parti va
rentrer dans son bureau ça c'était avant
et on a donc le après voilà ce qui va
voir dans un instant ara aprikian
laisser leur entrée dans son bureau
c'est bon à l'asie où pouvaient le
laisser rose bernard c'est pareil chez
toi
ohlala
on à merci
anna bravo a alors mon patron mon patron
cheryl comment ça va bah bien bien
m'attend je suis je suis retourné à la
crèche c'est ça ouais haras est ce que
vous pouvez vous asseoir à votre bureau
pour passer un peu parce qu'on a quand
même des dossiers à régler la sueur des
huit à merci art allez-y faites vous
plaisir
bon alors là c'est votre salaire quoi
sert la taille de mon bureau
c'est quoi ça c'est quoi ces des
salaires ça c'est le salaire il va être
à la taille de mon but aura va très bien
merci ea rajouts et qu'on l'applaudisse
très dense qui garde le sourire
regardez mon dieu qu'est ce qui se passe
à ras jdir le sourire mais j'ai pas
encore regardé mondiaux à quelqu'un qui
veut faire hara vous inquiétez pas on
remettra ça dans un an
d'accord tout en place ça vous fait
plaisir de passer l'année 2015 comme ça
mais moi je suis très content et je me
dis vraiment tous ces gens qui sont fait
changer leurs bureaux et leurs leur
appartement à par valérie damidot ils
ont bien du courage protègent l'hôtel
mona c'est vrai est franchement vous
liez que vous avez déjà vu un patron fer
plat cool c'est le mec et toulouse
il appelle la police nationale